oui ou non faut-il continuer à aider à
subventionner l'aéroport de dole qu'à
une infrastructure importante et qui
concerne aussi le des le les questions
économiques
moi je pense qu'il faut surtout aider
toutes les structures de tourisme de
tourisme durable voilà oui oxala europe
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas nous les gens
qui souhaitent prendre l'avion à dole
pourront prendre l'avion mais le
prendrons ouvrez prix d'un billet
d'avion donc non indique non en tout cas
à l'aide aux low cost ça c'est évident
parce que le tourisme local ça c'est une
vraie chance et le tourisme durable nous
allons aider les entreprises
les personnes qui souhaitent
effectivement créer de l'activité dans
ce secteur d'activité et ne pas croire
que comme à comme avant nous aurons un
tourisme international qui va revenir en
masse parce que de toute façon pour les
années qui viennent ce n'est pas
possible et ce n'est pas souhaitable
forcément pour la planète
la franche comté est la seule région en
france qui n'a pas un report for marqué
et aéroports c'est de l'économie c'est
du tourisme dokoui je considère que
c'est complètement anormal que la région
ne soit pas impliqué dans le
fonctionnement de l'aéroport que je suis
allé visiter et pour moi je souhaiterais
l'accompagner pour qu'il se développe et
qui le bénéficie aux flux économiques et
touristiques
l'accompagnement l'aéroport doit devenir
un aéroport régional c'est une
aberration qui ne soit pas déjà on peut
pas laisser le département du jura qui
très courageusement alors que seuls 10 %
des passagers sont jurassien paye la
quasi totalité des investissements être
seul donc demain l'aéroport qui est un
met en jeu un objet développement y
compris pour nos habitants mais
également pour le tourisme international
sera un aéroport régional gênés en 2001
de région je soutiendrai massivement cet
atout formidable pour notre région
c'est inadmissible que ce trésor parce
que l'aéroport est un trésor n'est pas
été valorisé accompagné soutenu par la
région socialistes c'est clairement des
emplois des investissements et aussi
développement du tourisme et donc le
tourisme c'est quoi des emplois non
délocalisables pour notre région
marie-guite dufay votre réponse dire que
nous n'avons pas soutenu l'aéroport de
dole tavaux et et il faut puisque nous
soutenons le fonctionnement de la plate
forme et que nous avons même doubler ce
fonctionnement
par solidarité précisément avec le
département du jura
par contre par contre effectivement nous
n'avons pas pris le pilotage de cet
aéroport
aujourd'hui il y a un différend une
discussion entre le département du jura
et nous sur le modèle
je ne crois pas au modèle tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui avec des touristes qui
partent de cet aéroport pour aller
dépenser leur pouvoir d'achat au maroc
maroc en tunisie au portugal 1
il faut faire venir des touristes du
nord qui viennent dépenser leur pouvoir
d'achat dans notre région dans nos
montagnes et dans nos vignobles ça on le
dit depuis des années j'avais toujours
dit la même chose toujours bas ses
enfants l'ont rapidement
oui ben je pense que il faut repenser
modèle économique de cet aéroport et
puis le mettre aussi dans une
perspective à terre régionales parce que
la logique petits fanions nous aussi on
veut notre aéroport international
il ya paris avec deux aéroports lyon
saint-exupéry et bâle mulhouse
la question doit se poser en termes de
réseau les habitants de l'yonne près de
sens ont de toute façon plus intérêt à
l'est les aéroports de paris que de se
rendre sur celui de dole tavaux de
réfléchissons autrement que de façon
étriqué comme ça arrête